Hi, today is, uh, is copyeditor was part two or of two parts, I guess, of a continuation of the story from Wednesday.
And let's see, I first I better start by making a correction to what I said.
I noticed another letter in the file after class. I had said that the that I that my paper was accepted in January of seventy six
and then the next I heard was February seventy seven with the copy edited review,
asking for quick service also. But no that's not true. I got it. I got it.
I got a letter in D on December twenty third.
Nineteen seventy six. So this must have arrived during a little after Christmas vacation saying I'm
sure you've been wondering what's happened to the article you were kind enough
to write at our request at long last we have an opportunity to present it and
and we'll go in the April issue of Scientific American boys like April issue.
So this was good. I suppose the press about two months this once.
So so now we will shortly undertake to edit the article or retype copy should be in your hands by the end of January.
It was pretty close, as I have indicated. You may correct it further rework that copy totally as you see fit.
While I'm at it, I'd like to ask you a favor biography and please send this by December thirty one.
Now I bring this out now because it talks about deadlines and publication and everything
and you and you all have a deadline of next Wednesday that was announced quite,
quite, quite well in advance. And this is the day when we want your term papers,
definitely two drafts to be definitely turned in this because I copies are going out to the different readers I mentioned.
Marie Claire is has agreed to look at them and and also Rosalie Stemmer and as and so, you know, we can't it's just like like the printing industry.
We can't accept the a delay that gets us out of this gets the cycle out.
Now, in fact, I think American was was amazingly good at at at their deadlines.
I, I was surprised. I mean, they lot of the things that I've been talking about all went on in the space of two weeks.
Jack, do we have to submit six camera ready copies of her?
No, no. We we are going to take care of the of the cost of reproducing the extra copies, but you'll get back more copies and then you turn in.
And if your paper has a lot of graphics in it, no, it's not three dimensional graphics.
Right. So give it a Xerox of will anyway.
That's what if there's something that isn't easily reproducible and we'd appreciate extra copies, but otherwise we we plan to.
But yeah, that's why we don't have a good color copier right here.
And so and so this, this took place in a in a short period of time.
I got the I got the edited things.
I think it was like February 7th. And then I got the page proofs from the printer February 20th or something like this and had to phone them in.
And I want to have phone call and so on, making sure that everything would go would go correct.
And then and this was the April issue, remember? And then I got I received a copy of the April issue, I think on March 25th, something like this,
a Scientific American, when they have an April issue, it comes out the last days of March.
And this is a little different from ACMD transactions on graphics where the October issue, I,
I got the galleys and, you know, and they were happy to be processing, I mean, in November and and so on.
But they do plan to have it out before the end of the year.
But this is this is this this is absolutely necessary because the thing is a snowballing effect.
You can see with it with the magazine Scientific American,
if it would as soon as the schedule would slip, then it would continue to slip and continue to slip.
And so they and so what is it, about eight, eight articles per per month or two every week,
go through there, go go through their doors and have to be in and out.
And they have to have they have to get it done. This also accounts for the I mean,
for for the occasional lapses in the in the quality of the writing that that that I pointed out a few examples of on Wednesday.
I show you another one. I mean, everybody can have their bad hair, bad hours when they're when they're doing a lot of things.
And the sentence I should point out that here I have been discussing several algorithms, the sole purpose of which is to determine the best.
Binary search tree. OK.
Now I took out the hyphen between binary and search, that's another issue.
But that was always reading to the, you know, the words of the professionals.
And it is just sounded very OK. The whole thing sounded awkward to me.
And it sounds like this might seem very much like examples of of a first approximation.
And so now in order to in order to to fix that up,
I had to change a few things which I think we're able to do to correct it without without completely rewriting the whole thing.
But what what what. What was my original sentence, I wonder? I don't.
But anyway, this was this was four for me, one of the most important paragraphs in the whole article,
because most scientists, especially in nineteen seventy five when I was writing this,
had had hardly heard of computer science and if they'd heard of it, they thought that computer science was,
was there in order to promote physics or chemistry or whatever their science was as a, as a tool for their, for their work.
They didn't see it as something that could be of interest to itself.
And I was always able to make a point here that that computer sciences is a discipline because it closes in on itself and
that we have an algorithm who who makes an algorithm that makes algorithms and and and improves and improves algorithms.
So it was it was something that if you were only working on on another field,
you wouldn't think of make having algorithms that would produce algorithms.
So this is what I was trying to get get get across the fact that algorithms who the study interesting and so on.
Right. And so on and oh I see that I had my sense had to be rewritten because I was I say we, I said no.
Note that we are speaking here about oh goodness.
Terrible things, terrible things I made here. Note that we are speaking here about algorithms whose sole purpose here.
I'm personifying an algorithm using the who to go with it and so on.
I guess that would would depend somebody.
I always think of them as, you know, more identifiable anyway so that I so that sentence had to be rewritten.
But but it came out. What.
Oh that's right, I did. Hey did it get it, did it get in the real thing. That's interesting.
Yeah. Huh.
Let's see. Where are we. Page thirty eight.
Oh come on. OK. OK.
OK. So what actually did they gain here.
Yeah. Yeah. Whose is in there. OK. We've made it here.
We should point out that the preceding paragraphs discuss the one whose sole purpose is to determine the best financial history.
In other words. OK. So this that that made it through actually.
Yeah. OK. And and the whole paragraph got really, really clobbered.
It says the example helps explain why in the study of how to properly employ computers, problems that are interesting in their own right arise.
And many of those problems require a new and interrelated set of concepts and techniques.
This was this was a huge, long, awkward sentences, some stuff coming out.
But everybody has their bad times, especially when they have to work under under deadlines.
And then I find out on this phone call that she was spending most of her time counting the letters in the lines so so that the captions would fit on.
Okay. Now it seems to go on with the with the article.
I think there were just a few things in that text.
And then I had my hand.
Now the rest of it I can show you on the other topics.
Okay. Now, in the original and the original, I had and I had suggested illustrations for them to use.
And and the first one was, was was not used in in the article.
And it would be it must have, must have been something would be rather expensive.
But I thought I wanted to to to start out with something that would be Eye-Catching and and and also interesting from historical point of view.
And so I. So the beginning of the article was talking about how it's it's easier to find.
Our phone numbers in the telephone book, if the names of people are in alphabetical order,
and I want to point out that this was this was known in two thousand years,
B.C., and there's this and then there's this this table of reciprocals of numbers that that was that was found from this from this point.
Sorry, it's upside down. I should have planned that.
I've had him. Yeah. So the numbers actually in in the form writing here are are in alphabetical sort of dictionary order.
And this was the first appearance I know of where things were really in in order.
And this is a very remarkable numerical table from several standpoints.
So I thought they might be able to get a photograph of this of this clay tablet from the loop.
But that probably was much more more difficult to do that work, worry about getting permissions and everything to be able to produce this.
So so that illustration was no use used.
But I still someday I would like to think about making facsimiles of this of this particular tablet, because I.
Because to me, the the task of sorting these these quantities into order with the technology of the time,
which I think is the first time in history when a problem was ever solved,
a data processing problem was solved that would have taken one more than one second on a modern computer.
And this this tablet is sort of the result of that. And from the I don't go a long story about the numbers, but if you if you look at the numbers,
there was no way to generate those numbers one at a time.
The only way to have done it is by putting together many, many pieces of data and sorting them into order, which would have taken a long time.
So if anybody has ever tried to sort 100 things into order, that seems easy on a computer.
But by. But when you when you go into thousands and so on, it's it's.
And these were multi place things. It was it was worth it was it was something worthwhile.
So I sort of be a nice artifact for computer scientists to have some kind of replica of this old this old clay tablet.
But they couldn't use that illustration. I think that's the only thing I have Mark here in the page proofs.
I showed you just a few things of the correction. But let me let me know.
Oh, yeah. By the way, this this got fixed, OK?
Because it was they changed less than or equal to less than when we were talking yesterday that I had less than equal science.
But it turned out that less than was thought was reasonable because the keys shouldn't be equal.
What? I left out the duplicates.
Oh yeah. That's. Oh, is that right? Oh, I see.
Oh, OK. Maybe that was OK. I forgot that little detail and I see.
So Adams is the grandson.
John Quincy Adams comes in. He doesn't he doesn't get get named in the database.
I've forgotten that little detail. See. Oh, OK.
Right. There's another Harrison.
I mean, I knew that Cleveland wasn't.
It was twice, but. OK. So. So.
Oh, I see. So that's why I didn't have a equals in there. All right. No problem.
Okay. Now here I, I. I wanted them to use floor brackets and see if they could see otherwise I would.
But here I am. Anyway I, I must've discussed this on the phone with, with her.
And so they, they, they actually were able to do that somehow with her over there.
They were able to shave her off. They don't look that great, but they at least they mean any notation.
I mean, this is fine. So this tells what the brackets mean.
So they were able to make that change. I got through over the phone and it's just typo here, here and there.
Now see China.
Sorry, I should be. Oh, but yeah. Speaking of brackets,
they they decided to use the the grade school rule about putting about putting square brackets outside of the outside of the parenthesis.
And I said please, the square. Brackets have other meanings to people, but that didn't make that correction did not get through.
They still have the square brackets in the final article. I forget why I had to put a yellow tag here.
I should have remembered that one. No, I don't see any.
It's just I guess I was just to show you what happens when when a typesetter that's not used to mathematics gets into the act.
What? What glitches happen. Now, this this actually they fixed it here.
But here you see that little that little dash in there for the clue to the
Caymans when the mathematics was was that was really break breaking them up.
And I don't know how we got that. I guess by changing the word different to distinct, though, they were able to solve that one.
But we had to resolve a bunch of these things on the phone.
Now, here's a case where where I had a subhead where where it it looked like it was falling in a bad place on the page.
But I also realized that I could that it was better to start to put the subhead on the previous page.
But just by seeing it here in in in a page proof a lot of them.
You see, things are only after you, after they're after they're improved.
And so by moving that that stuff in here, this is where I really I really started talking about the idea that you can do better than the best.
In other words, I just been talking my optimum algorithms here and I say better than the best.
So that as soon as something has been proved impossible, a lot of people immediately tried to do it anyway.
And so I like that. So I get into the into the idea that even though we've proved that binary search is the best way to do it,
we're gonna now show something that works better than binary search by changing
the ground rules and saying that search was the best way to do with comparisons.
But there are ways to do it without comparing things like that. I believe that's what happened here.
Now, that hyphenation, that's not so important that you have graphics in there.
OK. Here we had another communication problem with the with you know,
that they talk about a sub subset of the empty set and it comes out looking like, where are we here for?
I'm sorry. This is game of 20 questions. So this is a this is a fair way where you get the symbol for the for the empty set.
And and that's, of course, something that, again, causes problems when you're doing mathematical type setting.
You got it. When you whenever you use this.
Well, there's certain symbols that that that almost invariably get confused by by by typesetters who are inexperienced about not in this case.
I had a there was a one an l got changed to a one.
There were there were cases where they said this this this crossed zero.
Got too much change too. It came out OK. And the final article got changed to a very fee.
And there were then another I mean, in some font,
it's almost impossible to tell difference between Kappa and the bunch of other codes and zeros, obviously.
So proofreaders, sorry, but I wasn't accustomed to this kind of error here.
The thing that's totally, totally broke. And so so we had to discuss the, you know, this mathematics.
Just there, there, there, there a system we preserve.
So so we had to discuss it, but word by word over the telephone and make sure that we had the right number of letters in each line.
OK. Anything marked Mark.
So the most of the other problems were we're getting getting the mathematics straightened out.
And I guess they must have called somebody else in in on the job afterwards,
because this was certainly a problem that they had that they hadn't confronted before.
So anyway, the final article came out and as I said, we've been grimmett made these reprints, which have been sold by thousands of copies.
They did they they they work surprisingly carefully on these reprints like they
changed the they us a separate page numbers and they reset the text to give you,
you know, new page numbers in the captions and they. And this is in.
In two colors and everything, pretty, pretty fancy.
Now, this was the only article of mine that ever was translated into Arabic or actually Persian or Farsi, Persian language and.
And so that's another thing that's interesting.
When you write that you can that, you know, you you'll get mail years later, which were older, which are not now here.
I can't really tell much about what this says, and I don't know if it's a great translation or not.
But then in the footnotes, I can tell where you sort of keep up with them.
And in fact, they even they even translated the Persian name here, which was I mean, you think he came from northern Persia at that time, but very.
But they have you see here CalFed gets in there on this.
And so it comes in and it's fun. Like standard pork.
Yeah. Now, this was this came out in Iran before the shah was overthrown.
So but then not in this.
This is a right to left this language. But when you get to mathematics, it goes it goes left to right now, you might say it.
So that's the that's the convention. I Zohar showed me one of his his math texts from from Jerusalem that.
And it was it was quite a elaborate book of mathematics and it all.
It's all right to left. But the mathematics is left. The right. You switch back and forth.
You don't have to do that with with with. No, I mean, two, 20.
You can say that that's just a convention 90. The ones digit comes first and then the 10 stages.
But when you get to other formulas, that it goes that way.
So let's see what else is there on this thing.
Quite typical in a translation that when there's a word uncommon in the language,
they will they will show what what the original quadrillion and so on.
They weren't used to oil revenues yet at the time.
And especially hashing out hashing is the most funny word translated to other languages that I know.
I, I when when I wrote this book in French, they had to make a phone call to the to Paris,
to the academy to find out what they found out, that finally the word eyeshot had been had been produced.
But there was a long, long thing. And there's a dictionary in the math library of Chinese English computer glossary of changing.
If you look up hashing in there and it translates into fourteen characters. And so it comes out funny and other in other languages.
Oh well that's fun. Now the result of the whole thing, as I said, was, was, was painful for me at the time.
I was, I found it so much, so much re editing had to be done.
But I was like. But but on balance, I was really happy that that that my article was shaken up just to the extent that it was so that I could do this.
Otherwise, it would have come out in jargon that was invisible to me.
And. And people would want to thank Martin.
Gardner says that his greatest success, the reason for his success as a writer in mathematics,
he has more readers had and he wrote two deadlines every month.
Had a column for 25 years and had more. I am sure more people have read his his writings of mathematics than anybody else in the history of the world.
But his success is because he is not a mathematician.
He you know, the the more he would learn about about about mathematics, the less successful he would have been.
He was too much into it.
So he could he could remain an amateur, but still very interested, enthusiastic and with a network of people to cope to to send his stuff to to check.
But he never. But he never used too much jargon because he never got too deeply into the into the field himself.
And so there is something that a person who's talked too much into it can never, can ever hope to achieve without without professional help.
Now, Paul was my.
What did I. What did I slip on there?
Professional help. Professional help. Are without canceling out.
But counseling. Oh, OK.
Well, but the No.
I think of writing also the cooperative effort where where we help each other.
And and that and this always makes makes the final result better, as you know.
And this paper that I submitted, I Tripoli was also edited by a copy editor.
I'm not going to go through the long details of it, but I would hope that people would read the Stanford Sea Ice report instead.
I mean, there was a case where the final report came out and I just decided that it was two wasn't worth
the fight to to to food to put the thing back together again after they had destroyed it.
And, well, that was definitely my feeling anyway. But. But now I just show you a few of a few of the points here.
And they said they they said the other day they would never use zero and one as a symbol in their articles.
They always think you're supposed to spell them out even though they're there. I Tripoli transaction's I'm quoting theory and.
But one thing that the that they apparently had the policy in that journal is a L.O. gene means log base two without further explanation.
Now ELO G is one of the most ambiguous terms in mathematics. It means like Base Ten.
Everybody says these are common logarithms and end. And you just learn that they become extremely uncommon.
And as you listen, if you passed the 13th grade. Right. Yeah.
But there are the common logarithms. So LIFG means like base ten in most in most cases,
unless you read something on number theory where it means natural logarithm and if you read something on coding theory,
it means low base to evidentally and. And so I had used L.G.
That's my my preference is to use it in my books.
I hope he's right. L.G. for a log base two. And I had begun to believe that that was catching on.
But the editors changed that all the way through to LG and then gave no explanation what kind of logarithm they want.
So then I had to say, all of rhythm's here have radix, too.
And then I. I said, please, not t w.
But this is not radix to end.
And so I have to had to explain it here.
Here was a case of unity that I mentioned the other day that this term can be replaced by one at the expense of additional complexity.
And so here I changed it to unity. Better one as I had originally, but okay now.
So that's just a just a little bit of that paper.
So I triply probably l I shouldn't say this.
Never mind. I don't think they get the best copyeditors in their stack.
Let's see. Now I have this journal of number theory.
I was showing you referee reports from that I submitted to the journal because I like the referees, but I didn't realize that.
How how ugly their ellipsis would look in employment. I feel like this is this is something that just you think somehow a journalist,
specialist in mathematics would have some some feeling for cryptography.
But the thing I wanted to talk about was the recent thing with ACM, mostly because that's, I think, the most interesting issues.
This is the article that I said it's coming on in the October issue of the transactions on graphics,
although although it'll probably show up next month. And I thought some of the things the Copulatory did here were shocking, namely the data.
Is data singular or what? No, I think the word data data I don't even know how to pronounce it, but I know that it's one or the other.
A lot of people think that data can never be used as a singular.
And and I and this was going on 30 years ago when I when I was in college, people said,
you know, the word data is really a plural end up and people have used it by content, singular.
But so I started listening and I found out that on both coasts and in the middle and middle of America and everywhere,
people were using data very consistently. And it meant it meant something that was collective.
It could be the singular. And so.
When I when I published Volume one of the art of computer programing, which came out to January 68,
I was quite confident to say that this is a word that's used in both singular and plural.
And I meant and I said so, you know, there and I use it that way all through that series.
And I had copyeditors never changed it. So then I find out nineteen eighty seven I get back galley proofs from ACM saying that the original
data have I said has and I'm thinking of it as a collective collective thing and it certainly didn't,
didn't mean, you know, I certainly didn't, didn't set any signals through my brain when I wrote this that I was doing anything unusual.
And I certainly hear people talking and so on for more than 20 years now since the art of computer programing was written.
And besides, I I'm sure that this has just come up.
So I changed the word must so that so that it's both, you know, must is the same verb for singular plural so that you don't know.
So nobody, everybody, everybody's happy. But that's so.
So I wrote a letter to the to the ACM saying how shocking this wasn't.
You know, ACM, of all places should know about data and.
And then. So I got a letter back. And where is it here.
And wait do. But before I got the letter, I got a phone call and I actually married Marilyn Samuelsen is very good.
And she and we had a long discussion and it was very friendly and all.
But and she said that McGraw-Hill uses data in the singular only in its computer science books.
So they they publish, you know, one of the largest publishing outfits in the world at large.
And they have they have computer science books and everything else in computer science books.
They're allowed to use that in the singular. So that's it.
So apparently they thought, well, maybe I'm a member of a very small subgroup of the world where this happens.
But then she said The New York Times uses data in both singular and plural.
And this grieves her. Well, The New York Times.
My gosh,
that's pretty big up there in The New York Times is one of the most conservative in in in most ways on the way they own the way they do things.
When you say that, Mary, that's a yes.
Yeah, definitely yes. They're very concerned. Yeah.
Extremely so. Yeah. And I mean, I get the The International Herald Tribune, which is edited from The New York Times.
And I know sometimes but sometimes I get a free copy of The New York Times on my doorstep where they're trying to ask me to subscribe.
But I get this other this other from Paris comes a little later.
So I see The New York Times and then a couple days later I get my I get my International Herald Tribune and the articles.
And almost every sentence has a different has a different construction in it.
And I don't like it better in the International Herald Tribune, although they were originally written for the for The New York Times.
For The Washington Post. Well, so I know that they're very they're extremely concerned.
They have this long this huge, big style and everything.
But they allowed the singular book here.
She says, academic press and I Tripoli transactions.
Well, I actually we can write up, but academic academic press. I'm an editor for academic press.
I have to touch the academic press people about this. Is this true of the Journal of Algorithm?
Are they changing data? Well, OK, I have to do it.
But. And and but you certainly can misuse it in a way that that would.
It would be. And there are words like phenomena that I would not that I would that I would be very reactionary.
I would not know people. I also hear people saying talking I'm talking about this phenomena or something like this.
And I know that it's should be this phenomenon. And there's a but that's somehow that's wrong.
But that I know is OK. You know, once an automaton theory is a problem because nobody says automaton theory an instrument,
it's not really usually good to to use a plural in a. way.
But is that OK to say fine.
To have plural adjectives? OK. Well, that's good.
That makes me a lot happier because automata theory is definitely part of our language.
Yeah. Automaton as a singular automaton, the plural that term that, that time comes from, um.
An automaton from Greek, but they got these these strange plurals.
I guess I shouldn't go a long, long way about plurals.
OK. All right. That was one shocking thing. Now, here was a. Here was another thing which which got me.
Since the class number of IJA plus the class number of this are always equal to 63 now.
Now that one, though, and I think is, you know,
so so that when I led me to another line of my letter to the ACM saying this is is this not in general,
I thought that the copy editing was very carefully done. And and in fact, I remember I showed the galley proofs when they came in earlier this class.
And I said they looked like they had a high budget operation and things were being done, were being done rather well.
But then all of a sudden you see this, you know, then I get this data.
This with that same afternoon, I start looking at it. And I started wondering and and so.
So this one was definitely just a just a blunder. And everybody makes mistakes.
And so so she said and it's very rightly thought we take pride in the care we give to the of the papers we published.
Really we make our share of mistakes. Eight plus B are with such an error. And I assure you that it will be corrected on it.
So. Yeah. But she still doesn't seem to be convinced about that.
So I'm I don't know what to do about that. We talked about that and whether the other problem was another case, something that I know that.
Oh, I used the word I used a million in a formula.
I had this, you know, this quantity here. Fifteen hundred plus two squared divided by a million.
I didn't put any punctuation in there. I just said one zero zero zero zero zero zero as I would in Fortran program.
So they put commas in there because they have a rule saying when you have a number of more than four more than three digits,
it's more readable enough. More than 40 is 42, 40 gets.
OK. So if more more than four digits, you've got to break it up somehow order to be more readable.
Now, to me, this is incompatible with being in a formula.
There's there's two there's two sides of the style in the text where I would write a million with commas.
And there's a style in inside a math formula where I would never put a comma.
Certainly at least I'd have to have two commas, because otherwise in Europe they would think it's a decimal point.
Well, now they would prefer that I wrote ten to the Sixth and that would certainly sell this specific problem.
But what if the number hadn't been a million? What if it had been one, two, three, four, five, six, seven?
What would you do? So she refers me to I Tripolis standard to 68.
Oh man, that makes me worry very much. But she says for the sake of readability and search spaces, input into the formula.
So. So apparently according to I Tripolis standard one two sixty eight.
If I had, if I had, if that number had been one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, I would have to put spaces in there.
And that was supposed to improve the quality of the formula.
Now I can, I can see that this would be reasonable in a table where I'm presenting a lot of constants to a lot of coutu, too many figures.
But I but I would find it very distracting to see space.
And in fact, I even experimented with that when I was writing the tech program.
And there is a bunch of places in the American program actually where there is so
where there are constants that have to be given to to large to high precision.
And I have a comment and I tried putting in spaces are not these not great big spaces just fit any kind of spaces.
And it was uniformly worse in effect than putting the spaces in there.
So on. So there was another another issue about mathematics.
All right. Is one point two, three, four, five, six, seven times 10 to the seventh.
They can't put commas and they might still put spaces.
Yeah, that would be simple.
Actually, that's true. I could have divided the numerator denominator by some constant and also.
But in general,
I might my feeling is that the spaces are useful when you have when when you have a context of of high precision and tables and things like that.
But otherwise, it doesn't seem to me it seems to be out of out of its element.
And that's. Well, I've got 10 minutes to kill here and I won't.
And I've gone through the things I brought. That's very embarrassing.
But I thought you might know that I'm honest, too. So what should we talk about?
About my role. I these data as these data, as a plural, singular, if it's meant to talk about a collection of data as a whole.
Yeah. And a bunch of data given to our algorithm.
Yeah. Well, it's plural if it's a bunch of pieces of things. And so you say here's a here's a data.
You won't see that data. But data. Yeah.
Right. OK, that's good. I mean, we, we can always look for more examples in Scientific American in the in the article.
Because it's full of kids. Full of of of changes.
But that's the only thing I have I have here with me. So why don't we do that and follow something through from the beginning to the end.
The I don't know.
I think where I should go in the actually the most one of the most interesting things was,
was the both the algorithm at the end of the ad, at the end of that article, it's about it.
And so the idea of the article now is, I think I should say something about that.
First, George Forsyth told me that a scientist should think once in his lifetime saying something to the nonscientist,
to the to the general world at large instead of, you know, six or something, somebody outside of his own discipline.
And they said that's the hardest thing to do. It's much easier to write a song for an audience that that's like you and that you understand.
And so on. But when you're when you're addressing. Yeah.
But sometime in your life, you are to you are to think of trying to communicate with the larger public.
And I remember he told me this shortly before he died.
And it made an impression on me. And the year after he died, I spent in Norway and and was asked to give a public lecture at the university there.
And so this was the first time that I had faced the idea of giving a lecture to a non specialist group.
I was, what, thirty two years old or something.
But I had always talked to computer scientists before and.
And I thought, OK, once in my life I have to do this.
And I and I've done it three times now, but probably that's enough.
And I paid my dues for this is very difficult to try to.
To have something that will that that will be that you yourself are real interested in what you want.
But you somehow don't understand the other people's mindset enough.
But as I'm writing this article, I'm trying to I'm trying to make points about computer science, of course, that I got I get through.
It's a story that's interesting to them, something that they can identify with and that they won't.
And I get a feeling for computer science as a computer scientist, does it not, as a as.
As other people often view computer science.
So I'm trying to present to the spirit of the of the discipline, the way the way I see it.
It's just like, you know,
many people think mathematics is factoring polynomials and mathematicians don't factor polynomials very often after high school.
And and computer scientists are people who write Peyro programs or there are there people who who make video games or something?
I don't know. And that's all very interesting stuff, but not the soul of pure science that I see.
And so I try to get to trying to get this across. And so I, I chose to to present a sequence of algorithms for a certain task.
And it's and searching is something that people could identify with.
It's something that we always that we always have to consult tables and so we can get this across.
And then the. So I could make a progression. I could start with a with a brute force algorithm.
And then I could show that when it gets large, it's brute force, the algorithm is going to be is going to be terribly slow.
There's a better idea, binary search. And then I can show that we can make sure we can improve on binary search if we
know the if we know the frequencies of the of the elements that we're getting.
And we can improve even further if we use a method called hashing,
which is completely different from anything that a human being would ever want to do.
And and so now to to finally sort of clinch it.
I mean, at least for the computer scientist who is still reading, then I said, now you can actually use the you put both both ideas together.
You can have hashing and ordering and use the same.
And use an algorithm that where you agree. Computer hash address.
And then you start comparing with less than and greater than comparisons instead of equal unequal comparisons with hash.
And so this is the this is the end of of the article that I'm getting in here.
And I'm was a man I met in Norway that year.
And he he came to me once, in fact, and said to me, Don, what couldn't if the story is even better than that,
I wrote after I gave this public lecture, I was asked to write a article for a journal called Forth Things in It, which means scientific Norwegian.
I mean, it's the equivalent. It's the it's the scientific publication for.
For general scientific audiences in Norway. And and so I wrote it.
So this is really a rewrite of that article?
No, I mean, the themes that I had in this article, this is much expanded over the one that was unfortunate.
But the literally portions that means research news, but that means it's like Scientific American.
And and Angela was the man who helped me get it into good Norwegian as I wrote the first draft.
And I chose the variable names like H and V, V and H instead of Elna for left and right.
When I was talking binary search. So in a way, I, I made my notation Norwegian because Venstre is left.
And so you say V four for left there, you're variable.
But but then then I looked at my article and and I had and I had ended it with hashing and he came in and he came and he said, done.
Oh goodness. I just remember what I want to say in two minutes. And he came and said, Don't.
Couldn't you combine the ideas of searching, of alphabetic search with ordering, with with hashing?
I said, no, that's a foolish idea. It could possibly work. And and a few minutes later, I realized that he was absolutely right.
And there was a beautiful algorithm out there. And we finally wrote a paper about it.
But the main problem was I had just sent buying three off to be to be printed.
And it was in the section on harshing was all finished. And it was it was too late.
Oh. The other point I wanted to make is that this was April 1977 when the article came out saying Give American.
That's the month I started working on tax.
It was it was so these experiences that I had working with the publisher, as soon as these galley proofs and talking to the editors and so on.
And I was with leading me to focus on questions of type and type setting and mathematics and the problems of that that were happening.
And it turned out that the I guess it was the very beginning, a May.
Seventy seven when I when I actually designed it.
But in April, when I designed the first draft to take it up,
but in all in April was when I had sort of made the decision not to spend my sabbatical working on Volume four,
but to work on tacking on typesetting instead. And it was all probably be all because of the.
These are the concentrating on the words that we had and we had here to see this.
So to wrap it up, I was going to trace this through from the original draft to the to the copy edited version to the for the typeset.
So this is the problem can be alleviated by combining the idea of hashing with the
idea of alphabetic ordering as first suggested by O Embla in nineteen sixty three.
Now what did the copy editor do to this.
A 54 53.
Two fifty one were early. Algorithm. OK, so so I didn't like the word Olivia.
I don't know why. Maybe Mary can tell my very cloak and tell why this was all changed around.
But the sense came out in 1973, starting at the end.
Oh, Amla. Of what institution suggested that the problem of the unsuccessful search can be
alleviated by combining the concept of hashing with the advantage of alphabetical order?
That was what came out of that one. Now let's see.
I guess I'm not sure why or why.
My original sentence had to be changed. Usually I could figure out that there was some reason why.
But. But here it just seems to be perverse. OK, so suppose we have inserted the words X into the table in decreasing alphabetical order.
Suppose that the 31 communist English words are arranged in the table in decreasing alphabetical order.
Y. Oh, Mary, go America.
Please push the. I do know what it is, it's editorial policy at Scientific American to try to stress human contributions.
OK. If you notice that the two sentences continue doing in quite different positions.
You're very interested in the idea. Yeah, that's that's right. Okay, so the.
And that's that's a reasonable strategy for scientific work, for a scientific rating.
In fact, two, to point out that the I mean, this was just three, four years ago.
So people know it's it's a it's a it's a it's a clearly current thing.
All right. Sinding American had another editorial policy that said that they never display equation's.
This was one of the things that led to great problems. I didn't realize that. Okay.
But that was enough about about S.A.M. And I think you see the pros and cons of this.
But mostly the the fact that everybody is working hard makes it finally come up with a good product.